françois-xavier bellamy qui est tête de
liste des républicains aux élections
européennes du 26 mai prochain
[Musique]
bonjour françois xavier bellamy bonjour
ces élections européennes avant par les
mets d'abord l'actualité vous avez fait
entendre votre voix notamment sur les
réseaux sociaux propos de la
reconstruction de la cathédrale
notre-dame et vous avez mis en garde
contre toute tentative de reconstruction
qui ne serait pas à l'identique
est-ce que vous avez des craintes
notamment après le concours d'architecte
a lancé le président de la république
emmanuel macron j'ai simplement dit que
devant un tel monument nous avons besoin
de retrouver un peu d'humilité
je crois que nous ne sommes pas là pour
apporter comme le dit le président de la
république à un geste architectural
contemporain
pourquoi pas à ce monument historique
que nous recevons parce que on ne
cherche pas à augmenter une oeuvre d'art
qu'on reçoit et celui qui restaure la
joconde où la pietà n'a pas pour but ni
pour mission de lui a ajouté sa patte ce
que nous avons à faire d'abord c'est
transmettre cet héritage ce patrimoine
magnifique nous avons vu cette
cathédrale menacées de disparaître sous
nos yeux
d'ailleurs nous devons dire je crois
notre infinie reconnaissance envers les
pompiers de paris qui ont sauvé ce
monument qui nous ont permis aujourd'hui
de le restaurer il faut maintenant
tâcher de le redresser de le rétablir
pour le transmettre à ceux qui nous
suivront lorsqu en 1859 viollet le duc
avait bâti cette flèche qui est qui et
qui a été réduite en cendres lundi déjà
c'était quelque chose qui était un petit
peu polémique il n'était pas dans les
règles de l'art tels que la cathédrale
avait été construite au moyen-âge est ce
que il n'ya pas toujours une adaptation
finalement oro siècle dans lequel on
rebâtit un monument d'avoir violé le duc
ne prétendait pas fait un geste
architectural contemporain ils s'étaient
plongés dans l'architecturé médiévale et
ils en avaient tiré effectivement cette
flèche qui venait compléter la
restauration qu'il proposait de cette
cathédrale qui l'a sauvé et qui la sauve
et en la restituant dans son état
original cette flèche cette flèche elle
avait pour but de venir compléter le
travail des bâtisseurs du moyen-âge et
non pas d'ajouter la patte de viollet le
duc et puis on suit ainsi parce que plan
par exemple il ya une statue qui le
représente lui-même vous le savez mais
comme vous le savez si discrète que
personne ne peut la voir depuis
en tout cas nous leur avions ne peut pas
on doit s'interdire l'audace non je
crois qu'il faut d'ailleurs mettre en
oeuvre tous les moyens techniques
nécessaires pour avec les technologies
les plus avancées rétablir et restaurer
cette cathédrale comme on l'a fait pour
la sauver
on a utilisé des drones pour pouvoir
maîtriser l'incendié on doit utiliser
tous que la technologie contemporaine
pourra nous permettre d'utiliser pour
que cette cathédrale soit redressée mais
comme comme vous ne l'ignorez pas en
1964 a été établi une charte de venise
une charte très importante qui définit
des règles en matière de protection du
patrimoine
est-ce que j'ai simplement voulu dire
c'est au fond une manière de voir aussi
le travail des politiques je crois que
les politiques ne sont pas là pour tout
faire à la place de tout le monde ils
sont là d'abord pour permettre à ceux
qui savent de faire leur métier
nous avons d architecte en chef des
monuments historiques des architectes du
mahdi rejoindre emmanuel macron
d'endosser ce rôle je crois que je vais
laisser de donner à ceux qui savent les
moyens de travailler pour pouvoir que
faire en sorte que leur mission soit
accomplie
le président a fait une allocution
solennelle à propos de notre dame et un
conseil des ministres entier consacré à
cette question vous trouvez qu'il a fait
ce qu'il fallait qu'il en a trop fait
que quel est votre sentiment là-dessus
non c'est une très belle chose que le
président de la république vienne se se
saisir de cette question montre et le
nom de toute la nation que nous devions
nous engager dans ce travail de
restauration
je regrette simplement j'étais fière
présent à l'hommage qui a été rendu aux
pompiers de paris je regrette que le
président de la république dans son
allocution depuis l'elysée comme
christophe castaner ministre de
l'intérieur ministre des cultes
hier à paris n'est pas eu un mot pour
parler aux chrétiens aux catholiques au
coeur de ce moment si singulier pour eux
au coeur de cette île travail allemand
notamment du président mais il ya
quelque chose de très frappant
d'ailleurs l'archevêque de paris s'en
est ému je le comprends en un sens je
crois que ce lieu évidemment il
appartient à tous les français il
appartient même au monde entier qu'ils
se tournent vers paris aujourd'hui
mais il est aussi un lieu évidemment
singulier pourparlers pour les chrétiens
de notre pays dernière question sur ce
sujet bernard bernard arnault pardon le
patron de lvmh je trouve consternant
le flot de critiques qu'il a reçus parce
que sa fondation notamment à verser 200
millions d'euros pour la reconstruction
de notre dame comme d'autres est ce que
vous êtes d'accord avec lui
oui c'est assez consternant en effet
d'abord il faut que les français
comprennent ce mécanisme de réduction
d'impôts ça ne fait en rien il ment et
disparaît par la réalité de ce n est en
rien espérer de la réalité du don dans
toutes les situations
il se trouve que dans ce cas précis il
n'en bénéficiera pas mais ça ne reste
pas moins deux dents dans tous les cas
un don et je crois qu'on devrait être
capable de de s'enthousiasmer de ce que
dans notre pays
certains aient été capables d'investir
de réussir et vous savez ce nom qu'on
donne pour notre dame mais on ne donne
pas par exemple c'est la fondation abbé
pierre qui dit ça on donne pas pour les
associations qui aident les mal logés et
des sans abri qui est un petit peu de
poids deux mesures dans cette affaire
l'un n'empêche pas l'autre je crois que
nous sommes aussi un pays d'abord marqué
par une forte solidarité publique qui
s'exprime aussi à travers moins forte
pour cible pour rester dans la métaphore
hugolienne pour les misérables entre
guillemets alors une fois nous avons
l'un des pays les plus riches tribu tifo
monde c'est à dire que au fond à travers
la fiscalité nous finançons cette
solidarité qui est si nécessaire et si
légitime et ce que je crois c'est que je
suis d'accord avec la fondation abbé
pierre sur le fait de loger les plus
misérables de notre pays de pouvoir les
accompagner de pouvoir faire en sorte
que chacun soit soutenue par la
solidarité collective mais ce que je
crois c'est qu'on aurait tort d'opposer
la beauté de ce patrimoine qui doit être
effectivement préservé au profit de tous
quelles que soient leurs conditions avec
la nécessité de cette solidarité au fond
l'un et l'autre sont liés dans le fait
que nous faisons que nous formons une
société monsieur bellamy ce sont des
voeux pieux puisque effectivement
lorsqu'on regarde les chiffres ils sont
1 milliard en trois jours c'est beaucoup
plus que ce qui est donné pour les
associations qui aident qui aident les
plus pauvres c'est indiscutable je crois
qu'au contraire la générosité en france
est très fort si on regardait les
chiffres annuels je pense qu'on verrait
que ceux qui s'expriment dans le don aux
associations et est aussi une manière de
solidarité très importante au fil de
l'année mais je suis évidemment d'accord
avec vous sur la nécessité de cette
solidarité sur la nécessité de cette
générosité on parle de votre campagne
pour les européennes vous êtes donc tête
de liste certains mais ils sont pas
forcément objectif votre directeur de
campagne par indique vous êtes la divine
surprise de cette campagne
geoffroy didier il ya beaucoup de monde
dans les meetings mais en revanche les
intentions de vote elle plafonne pour
l'instant 14%
loin derrière le rassemblement national
où la république en marche comment allez
vous faire pour dépasser ce plafond de
verre à vous en quelque sorte c'est vrai
que nous vivons une belle campagne avec
une belle dynamique de campagne qui
n'est pas d'abord lié à moi qui est
d'abord lié à tout un travail d'équipé
avec agnès est vrai n'avait qu'un
audenge ans avec tous les policiers qui
forme avec moi cette équipe nous nous
portons aujourd'hui la grotte se
réveiller en france vous avez ce
sentiment
en tous les cas nous avons
la tâche de réveiller aussi ce débat
européen qui est si nécessaire pour
notre avenir nous avons un projet clair
nous avons fait soixante quinze
propositions sur les sujets les plus
fondamentaux sur la question migratoire
sur la question économique et
commerciale sur la question des
solidarités justement parce que c'est
derrière cette question européenne notre
avenir qui se joue nous en sommes
convaincus vous attendez le coup de main
de nicolas sarkozy ont dit voilà qui
serait bienvenu dans un beau meeting
avant le 26 mai vous l'attendez vous lui
demander de venir vous soutenir mais
c'est bien sûr son choix et c'est lui
seul qui le décidera moi je veux dire
que j'ai eu l'occasion d'échanger avec
lui de manière de manière régulière et
river publiquement l'a pas encore vu
vous soutenir venir sur une estrade il
faut voter
yola gino vinci mais il n'y a aucune
ambiguïté de sa part sur le fait qu' il
a été l'une des grandes figures de cette
famille politique il y reste aujourd'hui
évidemment attaché merci beaucoup
françois-xavier bellati impunément